des petits fours et codirectrice du
programme en droit international et
politiques internationales appliquées à
l'université de sherbrooke bonsoir jean
pierre dufour le président from donc
fait l'éloge bien sûr de cet accord
est-ce que c'est mieux quelle est la
différence en fait entre l'accord
bilatéral d'aujourd'hui avec le japon et
le partenariat transpacifique mais il ya
une différence majeure c'est que
l'accord qui a été conclu aujourd'hui
avec le japon c'est un accord sectoriel
qui ne couvre à peu près que
l'agriculture et le domaine numérique
le partenariat transpacifique auquel les
états unis étaient partis au début était
quand même un accord une appelle son
méga accord de libre échange qui
couvrirait 12 pays et qui couvrait à peu
près tous les secteurs du libre échange
mais est ce que le président a raison de
dire moi je pense que ces accords
sectoriels sont bien mieux que d'abord
un gros accord à 12 un gros partenariat
trans pacifique
6 quel président tu en penses et si ce
qu'il veut faire de plus en plus faire
des accords sectoriels pourquoi parce
qu'il veut faire en sorte que ça balance
commerciale il puisse la réguler à la
pièce or c'est impossible c'est illégal
de faire des accords sectoriels ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que les accords de
libre échange ce sont des exceptions à
une règle du commerce international qui
est la règle de la nation la plus
favorisée à l'organisation mondiale du
commerce ce qu'on dit c'est que les
états doivent donner les mêmes avantages
les mêmes concessions à tous les autres
membres de l'om sait sauf s'il ya une
exception et conclure un accord de libre
échange c'est une exception mais pour
que l'accord de libre échange puisse
réellement constitue une exception il
faut qu'ils respectent des conditions de
forme et de fond est une des conditions
de fond c'est de libérer de libéraliser
l'essentiel des échanges
ce qui signifie qu'un acteur c'est qu'un
accord sectoriel ne peut être une
exception au principe de la clause de la
nation la plus avancée c'est très
intéressant parce que l'accord de libre
échange en soit vous le décrivez comme
étant une exception à l'intérieur du mot
libre échange les pleins d'exception qui
ne sont pas tout le temps du libre
échange parce que quand même toute une
entente de tarifs douaniers qui
demeurent entre les deux pays
je regardais aujourd'hui le déficit
commercial sur les biens ses 67
milliards de dollars américains est
l'élément central de ça c'est
l'automobile et ce n'est pas dans
l'accord tout à fait effectivement donc
l'entente ne prévoit pas d'entente sur
l'automobile oui donc il sert à quoi cet
accord là exactement aujourd'hui il sert
by their en période pré l'octa
électorale à satisfaire la base
populaire de monsieur trump à dire aux
agriculteurs qu'ils se préoccupent de
leurs besoins on se rappelle que les
agriculteurs américains subissent en ce
moment quand même des sanctions
commerciales la part de la chine dans la
guerre commerciale avec la chine
ils ont de la difficulté à arriver et
cet accord le semble une bouffée d'air
frais donc j'ai plus que ce qu'a dit le
président tuant ce créneau mais la
victoire phénoménale pour les
agriculteurs américains
les producteurs de boeuf les producteurs
de bord mais pas tous les types de
producteurs n'ont effectivement les
japonais ont refusé par exemple que le
riz ou l'orge soit inclus dans l'accord
de libre-échange donc il y aura pas de
diminution des droits de douane par
rapport à certains produits
quand vous dites c'est illégal le japon
conclu signent des accords avec les
états unis qui sont illégaux ben oui
effectivement mais il faut se rappeler
qu'on est ici en situation de contrainte
les japonais ont en haut de la tête la
menace de se faire imposer des surtaxes
d'oise douanières sur le secteur de
l'automobile
donc ce qu'ils décident de faire c'est
de conclure un accord avec les
etats-unis après sur une fois qu'on dit
que c'est illégal vous savez comme moi
que qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire est-ce qu'il va y avoir des
conséquences
il faut qu'un pays décide de porter
plainte il va falloir qu'un pays portent
plainte devant l'organisation mondiale
du commerce sur la base fait que cet
accord de libre échange le est illégal
détourne le commerce international ne
respecte pas les conditions de fond est
ce que ça va faire on sait pas et donc
ce système de régulation du commerce
international marche pas très bien
aujourd'hui la surprise notre homme qui
impose son rythme oui malheureusement on
est vraiment en train d'assister à une
redéfinition des rapports de force des
méthodes de négociation commerciale
tout ce qu'on fait depuis 1947 est en
train en ce moment d'être revisitée par
le président trop et c'est un exemple
flagrant le le fait qu ont conclu un
accord sectoriel
quels sont les effets sur le canada qui
a signé le partenariat transpacifique
mais globalement je dirais que le canada
makelele lille les exportateurs
canadiens viennent de rencontrer un
nouveau partenaire qui va être en
compétition avec eux sur le marché
japonais bon parce que le canada une
entente de libre-échange avec le japon
dans le cadre du partenariat
transpacifique les états unis étaient
pas dans cet accord le donc le canada
pouvait refaire le commerce au japon
sans se soucier d'avoir par tous les
états unis comme compétiteur mais plus
spécifiquement je pense que ça peut
atteindre considérablement notre marché
d'exportation dans le domaine du sport
on sait qu'en ce moment on peut exporter
on a des gros problèmes d'exportation de
notre part entre autres en raison des
démesures center qui ont été prises par
la chine et donc le japon était un
marché d'exportation assez intéressant
et là on sait que ça va devenir vraiment
les exportations américaines vers le
japon qui va être avant si les accises
l'accord sectoriel annoncé aujourd'hui
entre les états unis et japon est ce
qu'on pourrait voir cela également avec
la chine qui les états unis recommencent
à négocier cette semaine mais tout est
possible mais la chine ont annoncé que
ça ne l'intéressait pas qu'elle n'avait
pôles d'intérêt à modifier ses
politiques et ses façons de faire au
niveau interne pour satisfaire les
américains et on sait que la chine ne
réagit pas tout à fait de la même façon
face aux états unis depuis quelques mois
alors que le japon reçu monsieur trump
en grande pompe au mois de mai dernier
la chine n'est pas tout à fait dans
cette posture la chine jouent aux gros
bras en ce moment puis envers qu'est ce
que ça va donner
je vous remercie beaucoup très très
prisé